with bad information I I I'm not I'm
sorry but I don't believe in this whole
women intuition they just feel
everything and ignore everything I don't
believe in that I believe that a lot of
women Unfortunately today got really
really bad information they thought it
was true and now their lives are wrecked
because of it our boys lied to about how
to attract women boys 100 okay
I don't know if they're lied to but
they're maybe just not giving it but
it's the the correct information like
being nice since
last three questions because we have the
heart out in about 10 minutes we want to
get to Super chats uh you brought him up
and you just did an interview with him
recently so I feel the need just to ask
you about this so we're talking about
red pill you brought up the name Andrew
Tate you just did a massive interview
with him four days ago I want to say
whatever it was we've all seen the
breaking news as of yesterday or
whatever it was that he was arrested in
Romania for human trafficking or sex
trafficking or money laundering of what
it is
um my question let's start with you
every everything that we've no good bad
ugly about Tate do you think he's a net
positive or a net negative for society
today on that positive you think so oh
yeah really yeah explain why
um to me one of the things I don't know
him personally so I can't attest to it
I'm a long-form Content guy so if I'm
going to criticize you I'm watching long
phone content and come to my conclusions
one of the things I do really love about
Tate is the evolution and the growth I'm
big on that I love the evolution the
growth and I think States one of Tate's
core messages is men and women coming
together he he's constantly pushing that
he's constantly talking about that and
and he I believe he has a genuine desire
to see men win the jokes the Antics I
love jokes the Antics so I can I can
Overlook it personally I know most
people can't but I do believe he's an
individual recently who's working who's
working really hard to at least make the
world a better place yeah I respect that
obviously I assume you think he's a net
positive I want to know what you think
the best advice that Tate gives to men
out there the best what do I think is
the best advice he gives to men
um oh gosh there's so many I like when
he calls people brokies okay yeah I just
think it's funny
um I like what he talks about having a
strong body and a strong mind I think
that's like that's kind of where you
have to start with in life like even
that's that could go for women too you
know if you're not healthy
respect yeah anyway we're gonna see
what's gonna happen with him I think uh
there's more news out there that he's
going to be have to be stuck in Romania
for the next 30 days I don't know we'll
see what happened is but I listen we
talked about this earlier on pbd podcast
there's three things that I think Tate
stands for okay and the the third one I
think is the most important but the top
two are the ones that get all the clicks
and get all the highlighted and
basically make all the headlines number
one is the
um chauvinism component of it and uh
basically being a toxic masculinity type
of guy which that that that that that
that is what grabs headlines chauvinist
uh Andrew Tate or uh what's the other
term for showmanism
misogynistic exactly uh but that that's
sort of the headline the number two is
everything he talks about with the
systems and the Matrix and just dude was
attacked when we did our interview out
there with him he got taken down by I
think it was Facebook first Instagram
then it turned out to be Snapchat
YouTube uh uh Tick Tock bing bing bing
and then it came Uber then came Lyft
then it came PayPal then came stripe
then came Airbnb and it was just like
with one press of the button the system
took him down so I think people want to
highlight that but I think if you really
watch his long-form content all he's
talking about is male self-improvement
yeah make your money stop being a Brokey
um work out deal with some [ __ ] like be
resilient be tough be strong be a badass
like be the dude that that that the
woman wants not the woman not to do that
you think that the woman wants you see
what I'm saying right there and I think
that advice gets lost for the common
viewer they don't really appreciate what
he's actually doing so I fully agree
that he's a net positive for society
male Improvement next question I want to
know real quickly because we have a few
times male Improvement how do you think
male Improvement and the male
Improvement space has evolved and where
do you see it headed from here I
personally
um am very if I'm being honest I don't
think the male Improvement space has
evolved I think it's devolved I think
what's happened is you have a lot of
these these new actors who are into
space for clicks views and attention and
money that's why they're in their space
they're genuinely not trying to see men
win it's like they're kind of like CNN
right it's CNN trying to build Amer
build America together than the Trump
ever no we're just trying to make
dollars and get clicks so so what's
happened is we have a whole generation
of these new influencers who's entering
into the space who really don't have the
best interest for men and so to me I'm
really excited about content creators
like a Hamza and individuals who
genuinely want to see men's lives
improved so there is some good things in
the space but I definitely see the space
evolving because you have a lot of these
new characters who just want clicks
views and attention and I believe it's
not best for the society as a whole
gotcha you want to weigh in on that I
know you don't give advice to men
but for your but you kind of are
peripherally in the men's advice space
where do you see it headed
um I mean I would look at more of what
you're saying as a caution sign
um I I think that there's a lot of great
guys in the space that are helping men
and they're very passionate about it and
I think they do a good job
Pearl is gonna run for some sort of
political position the diplomacy on you
is amazing are you familiar with a guy
my name is Derek Jackson
okay that's
I feel like it's like a passive
aggressive no I was curious I was
curious if she was familiar with Derek
Jackson because one of the criticisms
that they gave about Derek Jackson was
Derek Jackson was a guy who did he likes
to say that I don't mean what I say like
that's what he said last time one of the
criticisms that people gave with Derek
Jackson
one of the criticisms that people gave
with Derek Jackson was he was a guy who
went crazy hard on guys so he would say
every single point that women believed
women would say about guys but because
he was a man he would say and people
were really upset about him so to me it
was just like there was I'm just very
curious if she'd ever heard people like
heard about him or heard comparison
which she obviously told me she did
because yeah from you
oh yeah yeah all right yeah uh okay
listen before we wrap up now you've got
some super chats I do have to do super
chats yeah okay do you wanna you wanna
go through that and then we'll do a wrap
up yes okay we're gonna go through them
as fast as I can because we got a lot
today so thank you all I'm gonna be with
you guys in the super chats go fast no
questions we don't have time okay so
comments gonna ask a question we can
maybe answer it in another show or
something like that you got it so I'm
gonna read the ten dollars and up
because we do have a lot of them so let
me start
we've got one from uh zanchelli uh
children on marriage versus children
with a random chick marriage is not fair
if it doesn't protect you from having a
child taken away cheers to Brazil sorry
for my English mistakes you did a good
job uh Glenn Lawrence uh Ruslan KD how
about you and sit down I would get back
to Los Angeles we sit down and we talk
about it from Biblical standpoint since
you have a lot to say
most repeal guys this is the next chat
most vertical guys would say common law
marriage if you want kids but do it in a
state that doesn't recognize common law
marriage or community property that's
from come on man podcast uh then we have
the modern stay-at-home mom I see a
feast's point teach men how to pick good
women at a very least if divorce happens
you have the same values and a chance of
the most valuable asset which is
children as many
as men I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible